welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy that's
been shouting Hale Snyder for the past
20 minutes at a picture of Joss Whedon
the Batman news has been coming thick
and fast recently in the wake of the
sadaqa announcement and though it has
massively overshadowed it throughout
this video we're gonna be breaking down
some of the major developments that you
may have missed this video covers the
fake reports that ben affleck will be
replacing Robert Pattinson the
interviews by Jeffrey Wright that
discussed the Batmobile and some more
penguin news that give us further hints
as to what the character might be like
in the film obviously there will be
heavy Snider's here so if you don't
anything potentially snyder at about the
movie then I highly recommend that you
just read now the video make sure you
sub snyder to the channel for videos
like this every day and please drop a
thumbs up if you enjoy the content
without the way thank you for clicking
the video now let's get into our
breakdown of Snyder s Snyder s Snyder
okay so first up I want to discuss a
story that you might have seen on the
internet this week that is that Ben
Affleck will be back as the Batman and
that he will be replacing Robert
Pattinson in the role this came in the
wake of the positive reaction to the
Justice League Snyder Cup being
announced and the story started to pick
up traction after Ben Affleck posted a
video staying how happy he was to see
the film finally getting released I went
through as much of the Internet as I
could and the source of the story seems
to stem from YouTube channel comic book
cast - who says that he saw the rumors
of Robert Pattinson being fired from the
Batman you can watch the video for
yourself but apparently they've seen us
everywhere and it's all over the
Internet in the video he said Pattinson
was fired because he hasn't been working
out and Matt Reeves has gone quiet after
the announcement of the snedecker
because the film is getting changed
quite a lot according to the video
there's there's loads of rumors flowing
about and the main source is bro dude
trust me I seen them again I've been
unable to find anything from before this
video so it does seem that it stems from
this I always question videos and
reports like this as if there's a lot of
sources on the story then you should be
able to drop at least one in the video
much in the same way that I'm using this
video
as a source the comparison is made that
we heard rumors about Ben Affleck
quitting as The Dark Knight before it
happened and that this is the situation
in Reverse where we learn that he's
coming back before he even does now is
this true absolutely not
I obviously cannot verify this but you
don't have to be the world's greatest
detective to know that something seems a
bit off about this story I'm willing to
put my Batmobile collection on the fact
that this is untrue and that Warner
Brothers haven't even considered firing
Pattinson they've spent hundreds of
millions of dollars on casting costuming
flying crew over to England to film
building sets and getting actors in the
role to the point that it would be the
stupidest thing since Mr Freeze came out
spouting ice puns to shut the project
down Ben Affleck is 47 if his movie was
to be rushed into production today by
the time it was released he would almost
be 50 years old Robert Pattinson is
about to start internet a film that will
likely propel his career forward
massively and it just seems ridiculous
that these kind of rumors even pick up
any steam when there's no sources to
support them and if you think about it
for more than five seconds it just
doesn't make sense
comic book casts say that the snyder cut
release has shown you can't predict the
way things will go but that was a film
that had the majority of its scenes
already shot to the point that all the
studio is doing is cleaning up the cgi
and recording additional dialogue this
is one of the stupidest rumors i've ever
heard and if it comes true I'll eat my
bat actually that that's probably not
probably not a good idea if his story is
reporting on something that requires at
least evidence it should have more than
just a Cena bro trust me bro sources
insiders inside of my imagination so
yeah I doubt that it's true in any form
anyway I just had to get that out the
way before we get into the actual news
Jeffrey Wright has recently been doing
press rounds in the wake of Westworld
and of course to promote the upcoming
film Batman as long as the project
hasn't been completely shut down which a
Cena Pro trust me in an interview with
The Hollywood Reporter the actors say
that the movie was going to be in
evolution of the character he said
they're working together to create a
mood create an idea a setting and a tone
I'll leave the full piece linked below
if you want to read it but the bit that
has everyone talking is Right statement
that the Batmobile will be hand-built by
Bruce Wayne
Wright said I read the script for the
Batmobile and I was like yeah that's it
Bruce Wayne created the most badass
muscle car you could imagine but it's
grounded in Gotham it's grounded in
Americana so we now know for definite
that Bruce will be the one behind the
design of the new car when it was first
shown to the world many said that they
thought it looked like something a
mechanic would create I think it really
plays out what the film will be like
this will be a grounded Batman that
though he has a lot of resources is
still keeping himself to himself he
hasn't recruited Lucius yet he doesn't
have an arsenal of weaponry he's
basically trying to figure things out
for himself and to find out what works
this design is also reflected across all
of the film that we've seen so far the
bat bike of course looks like it's been
made by one person and the bat suit
itself looks like it's been pieced
together and made out of existing
materials yes we're still on the theory
that the chess pieces Joe chills gun
this could end up being the most
realistic Batman that we've ever seen
put to screen
and whilst Nolan's was very true to life
sometimes did stretch the imagination
with the memory cloth and him breaking
his back which was fixed by someone
punching it I know it was his vertebrae
yeah just just stop writing that comment
right now you I know he about to write
it anyway right further went on to have
an interview with Sirius Radio we'll
play the clip in just a bit
but he basically talks about playing
Gordon notice he shuts down playing
Commissioner Gordon so it's likely that
he's gonna just be Detective Gordon at
this point let's get into the clip you
play Police Commissioner Gordon in the
next Batman movie with Robert Pattinson
what is you're just just what is your
take on Commissioner Gordon well I'll
say this I played Gordon I'll just say
that so yes I played Geminoid
and my take is well
way that I kind of explained what we're
doing is that like with any film we're
working together to create a mood to
create an idea a setting a tone and
that's all being led of course by Matt
Reeves he's created this vision for this
thing that of course is his is the next
evolution you know since 1939 when these
stories began this is the next evolution
of you know of Gotham and so I'm working
off what Matt you know the stage that
Matt is providing and also working off
what Robert is doing and you know we're
trying to create something together that
is you know that's our own but it's also
Batman and so I think if you look at
some of the images that you know that
matt has released and he he would
release these things on Twitter you know
we'd be filming it like boom all of a
sudden you know my phone would start
smoking like oh yeah you see if you know
Rob in the suit or the Batmobiles which
like the Batmobile the shots of that
movie which are which I read that
description the Batmobile in the script
and I was like yeah that's it and that
really in some ways is kind of
indicative that you know of what we're
doing and that it's it's something that
you recognize something that super hyped
up it's like super a Hemi fact that car
but it's also yeah of course we took
these you know parts and he created the
most badass muscle car that you could
possibly imagine but it's grounded in
Gotham it's grounded in Americana
you know it's something that you can
relate to and I think you know those are
the types of elements that were really
kind of driving lest it you know as we
played within this how do we make it
gritty real Gotham and at the same time
give it all you know like the the you
know the veneer and the the excitement
that you expect from a Batman franchise
so yeah lots of things in that that
really speak to how grounded the movie
will be and how much it will sort of
take the character in a new and
surprising direction that also ties in
to its long and rich history as someone
who loves a more realistic Batman to say
that the god version that we get in
things like Grant Morrison's run and the
Justice League movie I'm very excited to
see this on screen as I definitely feel
like it's the best version of the
character out there and finally we now
know a lot more about Colin Farrell's
penguin the actor recently spoke to Good
Morning America and discussed how much
of a role he'll be playing in the film
initially it was thought that he
alongside the Riddler would be tied as
the main villain of the piece
however Ferrell has walked this back
slightly and said that he only has a few
scenes when discussing how lockdown had
impacted the role he said I had only
started it and I can't wait to get back
the creation of it the aesthetic of the
character has been fun and I'm really
excited to get back and explore it and I
haven't got that much to do I have a
certain amount in the film I'm not all
over it by any means but there are a
couple of tasty scenes I have in it and
my creation and I can't wait to get back
yeah I totally feel like it's something
that I have not had the opportunity to
explore before feels original and fun
but I'm only at the start of the journey
so I can't wait to get back and really
get into it so it does seem that the
penguin will be more of a background
character that adds to Gotham rather
than being the main villain this may be
similar to how Falcone was in Batman
Begins and whilst the scene that the
character has sound tasty I don't know
if he will really have much of an effect
on the overall storyline now from this
we can take that the Riddler will indeed
be the main driving force of the plot
that he will be the person that takes
the center stage in all of this I
actually think this statement also sort
of solidifies that penguin might be the
mayor in the movie and then he may be a
politician rather than someone that
Batman goes head-to-head with in
nightclubs and on rooftops we do know
that there will be a mayoral candidate
in the film known as Bela rial so
perhaps she is running in opposition to
the villain either way there's a lot of
things I look forward to and I love
picking apart the tidbits like this and
to end the video I've actually also
heard a room
that definition will be replacing Robert
Pattinson as the Batman it's probably a
rumor that you've seen because I've seen
it everywhere on the internet like dude
bro trust me trust me yeah and hit the
thumbs up button much love anyway if
you'd now be fully up to date with all
of the news on the Batman so thanks for
sticking with me until the end of the
video if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and if you
missed our last breakdown of the film
then that's gonna be linked at the end
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below you
massively appreciate it and I said thank
you you get access to content early
gonna come chat to us after the show
either follow us at heavy spoilers or
click the disc or link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this Monty
can win the Marvel phase 3 part 2 boxing
all you have to do is comment on a video
and make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on the more of a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
but when it's gonna be chosen at random
on the 15th of June and the set will be
shipped out from lint ever gets the
price it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like in
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll say next
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]